dear for after your question about
assessment in education and the world
teachers is very important itself first
we need to know what are the impact of
education when education is about
learning to what extent students are
learning is not something which is
measured enough
we need to measure it and this
information needs to feed back into the
teachers teacher are the masculine
including education and teacher need to
assess what their students are learning
what are the gap in knowledge and then
adapt their teaching to the needs of the
student at the same time at the level of
country we need to know how much the
country as a whole is learning and what
type of skills are being imparted to the
labor force and and at the same time
country needs to compare yourself to
other countries because if the
generation is doing well in the same
mathematics and science reading
skills this is an idea what its future
competitiveness in the world so it's
very important to assess but at the same
time people see assessment as a measure
of accountability and want to link it
measuring the performance of teacher in
fact it's more important to
teaching and learning assessment is an
integral part the teaching and learning
process and not necessarily a measure of
performance but it can be used also and
this is a debate human cultures